(upbeat music)
- Welcome everyone to this new
episode of "Firm Learning",
probably wonder where I am right now,
this for sure is a bit
of an unusual location,
I'm currently in Switzerland.
So yesterday I took the train
from Munich to St. Gallen,
and the business heavy
people probably know
that St. Gallen is the hometown
of the University St. Gallen,
the (indistinct) St. Gallen,
which is arguably the best university
in the German-speaking area.
So I'm lecturer for the
MBA program at St. Gallen
for communications and
slight writing topics.
It's on the first time
that we are back in class,
in the lecture rooms,
away from online teaching
due to the situation,
so I'm very excited for
this new opportunity,
this new experience here.
So you will now follow me for the day,
I will share a couple of insights,
what it's like to do an MBA,
in general, do an MBA at St. Gallen.
So trust this video, will
be insightful to everyone
who wants to know what
it's like to do an MBA,
and potentially also whether an MBA
is the right thing for you to do.
So let's do it, let's start.
At University of St. Gallen,
I teach at the full-time
and the part-time MBA program,
I especially focused on topics,
such as professional communication,
slide writing techniques,
and also many of these other topics
that you are very familiar with,
if you regularly follow the channel.
This is really a passion of mine,
so I'm very happy to be able to contribute
to the business education of
the future leaders in this way.
It's really amazing,
just thinking back how
a couple of years ago,
I was sitting on the other side
of this room here, really at the desk,
not at St. Gallen, but in
NCR (indistinct) MBA program,
and being aiding honor to teacher here.
This is a great experience,
today, we've talked a lot
about top down communication,
forming storylines for your presentations.
So all these skills that
surely come in handy
in our different types of
business presentation context,
because at the end of the day,
this is what the MBA is all about.
It's not only about academia,
but really also learning
these more softer professional skills,
that of course, are so
important to present well,
to communicate well,
do this in front of very senior audiences,
do this in front of board members.
This is exactly what you
will learn in the MBA,
where also, I personally took so much away
at NCR experience.
So here with me,
I have Federica from the MBA
class of St. Gallen of 2022.
thank you for joining me Federica.
- Thank you, for inviting me.
- Can you just share a little
bit about your background?
What did you do prior to the MBA?
- Yes, of course, I'm Italian,
I've studied mathematics in Italy
and then had a bit of experience
in project management,
mainly in the fashion industry.
- So what is the course here in St. Gallen
that's so far you enjoyed most?
What was the most
significant learning for you?
- I have to say that I really enjoyed
capital markets course.
This is something I
really never did before,
but a teaching method was so diverse
and also we had the impression to really
learn something that is
happening in the world
and very important for every MBA students.
- That very much resonates
because this is also I
experienced when I did my MBA,
but maybe for the uninitiated out there,
can you share a couple of thoughts on
what's distinctive about
the MBA teaching method?
How does it work here in St. Gallen?
- Yeah.
- What makes it special?
- Of course, so I've
studied in Italy University
and the other methodology
was completely different.
Like a professor telling you
things, things, same things,
you have to study a lot and
then finally have an exam.
Here, the story is completely different,
you always have group works to do,
different methods like, of
course, frontal lessons,
but also discussions, workshops,
and a lot of exams also.
- Exactly, I mean, that's really
I think the point of an MBA?
It's not so much about academia,
but it's really about hands-on management
and business knowledge,
and this of course, is
what makes it valuable.
Do you happen to look back
at the last weeks already,
one key memory of a moment
that you want to share?
- So, first of all,
I have to say that the first
day of MBA was memorable,
because it was the first time
being together with almost
50 people in a same big room.
And after this COVID period,
this was so strange to be all
together, really shaking hands
- I can imagine.
- And meeting people that were
all really happy to start
this journey together.
This was the super...
The most exciting moment I have to say,
so far, yeah.
- Sounds amazing.
Thank you, appreciate it.
So it's a pleasure to also meet you,
Alisa, you're also part
of the current MBA cohort.
So I'm standing here with Payel,
who's also part of the current MBA class.
Thank you, Miklos for
taking your time as well,
part of the current MBA cohort St. Gullen.
Thank you for joining me Matej-
- Sure
- Much appreciated.
Thank you Ali, for joining me year as well
at University of St. Gallen.
- So before the NBA, I was
a finance professional.
I've got around five years of
experience with FMCG industry.
- What I've lived in the
last six years in Finland,
and I was working in
operational procurement
for an manufacturing company.
- So I worked in financial industries,
I was the regional manager
in insurance company.
Last year before joining the MBA,
I spent a year in digital transformation
of the same 120 year
old, insurance company.
And I also co-founded two companies.
- I was working in a ministry
of treasury and finance
for the last nine years.
The last three years,
I worked as a project manager
and government consultant.
- I am a PhD in music theory.
- Wow.
- I was a concert pianist
before that, I've been working
as a sustainability consultant so far.
- What I really like here, is that we get
to meet all these different companies,
because that's something that
you don't really get to do
at school or in your normal work.
So of course, like being
exposed to so many companies
is something that I really appreciate.
For example, on Tuesday,
I went to a company called On Running
and after that I went
to the Crypto Finance.
- So I think I was particularly impressed
that our accounting professor, Tommy Din,
started her first entire
lecture talking about
environmental accounting measures,
which I thought was very important,
especially for the present moment.
- In the first week, we
had to launch a rocket.
We didn't know how to do it,
but we sat down, we were the diverse team
and I would wished to say
that we launched till the
moon, but our rocket exploded.
But it was a great learning experience.
- So let's go to the moon,
thank you, God bless.
- Absolutely, thanks.
- University of St. Gallen
is the leading university
in the German-speaking area.
So I feel very honored,
that I've been asked to
conduct here the lecture
for the MBA program.
Here with me I have Sander,
from the university team of St. Gallen.
- If you're interested in doing an MBA,
and wanna learn more
about general business,
finance, strategy, and
a lot in communication,
or career development,
click on the link below
to learn more about our MBA at
the university of St. Gallen.
- I did an MBA myself,
I did my MBA at Insead,
in 2015 and 2016.
I was working on both campuses
in France and in Singapore,
and really have the full experience there.
I just wanted to share with you
the top three reasons or top three things
that I got out of the MBA for myself.
And I hope, of course,
this helps potentially also you to decide,
whether this is something
that makes sense for you too.
And the first is for
sure, amazing connections.
So especially the Insead MBA,
but I trust here also St.
Gallen, it's no different.
You meet so many people in the MBA program
from so many different
regions and geographies.
I know for myself, that
if I all want to travel
in almost every country in the world,
it's more less guaranteed,
that I would know a person there
or that at least will be able
to have someone introduce me there
to a person, to a local, who
can maybe guide me around
potentially even given
me a place to sleep.
And of course, this is a network
that also on the professional
side, is extremely valuable.
I recently was looking for
contacts at a specific company,
I was looking that company up on LinkedIn,
and I saw that several
of my old MBA friends,
who were working at the company.
That of course, is huge
and really a great
opportunity to tap into.
The second is the MBA being a wild card
that you can pull out.
So, frankly, this is not
really the way how I used it,
but I saw that many other people used it.
Is that they do the MBA
because they wanna make
a career transition,
and this I think is an
opportunity that many people have.
There may be a work in
a specific industry,
or maybe a work in a specific function
and you want to do a switch,
and to some extent, I
think the MBA is something
that is used to really reset your career,
that is often really also
accepted by employers,
that after you did an MBA,
do something completely different.
And this is actually awesome opportunity
where I see that people
wanna get into consulting,
maybe in a firm like McKinsey, BCG, Bain.
So these MBB consulting firms,
if they have a background
maybe in Big 4, for instance,
then they can indeed use an
MBA to then also do the switch
because frankly, it's
sometimes very difficult
to then transition from MIT consulting
or from Big 4 to MAB,
but if you do the MBA,
this is often a great
opportunity to do exactly that.
And last but not least, of
course, it's also the learnings,
and what learnings exactly
what we get out of it
will also depend on the
type of program that you do.
So the one thing of
course, are the lectures,
the input that you get here,
you of course, it would benefit most
if you don't have a
business background yet.
So if you're, for instance,
an engineer have never
attended a business lecture,
this would then of course,
be really great and eye opening for you.
For me personally,
I already did have some
business education,
so still learn something new,
but probably the biggest
takeaway from that perspective
was really the cultural awareness.
So for me, having spent half
of the program in Singapore,
traveling to lots of Asian
countries in Southeast Asia,
spending several weeks
in China, for instance,
the experiences that I did there,
the cultural sensitivity
that this gave to me
was really eye opening for me.
I took so much away from that
and which was a fundamental part of,
for my personal learning experience
that I had during the MBA.
So hope you found this insightful,
if you have any more questions
on what it's like to do an MBA,
please leave me a comment
below in the comment section.
Once again, if you want to read more
about the university of
St. Gallen and the MBA,
Link to information pages is
below in the video description,
they're happy to reach out to you,
provide you with all the
information that is needed.
Again, if it took any value
out of this video at all,
please hit the like button
for the YouTube algorithm
and also very big thanks to
all members of "Firm Learning,"
thanks for our support.
My name is Heinrich, I'm the
host here at "Firm Learning,"
I release videos every single Saturday.
So see you again next week,
until then all the best, and bye-bye.